good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight time for civics class
the abbreviated version here's how
democracies work in a democracy voters
strike a highly straightforward deal
with the government that rules them
here's what it is politicians do their
best to improve your life in exchange
for that you vote for them that is a
voluntary arrangement it works pretty
well
for 250 years that's how it's worked
here in the united states but suddenly
not anymore
during his entire first year in office
joe biden did virtually nothing to
improve the actual lives of actual
american citizens and he didn't because
he didn't even really try
making voters happy is not a feature of
the equity agenda punishment is the
point of the equity agenda inflicting
pain on the right people dispensing
rough justice meeting out reparations by
other names
in his speeches you can see clearly how
joe biden feels about america he's
deeply disappointed in the country and
he's annoyed with the people who lives
here
biden doesn't cajole voters he harangues
and berates them he patronizes them and
issues threats you cause the corona
pandemic you're stupid and selfish no
fourth of july hot dogs until you obey
so for an american president this is an
entirely new way of governing and you've
got to wonder how long it can continue
how exactly are democrats going to hold
on to power in the coming midterm
elections
if you think about it there's only one
way they can do that they've got to
create a new form of government one that
keeps incumbents in power forever no
matter what they do no matter how
incompetent and destructive they may be
one way to do that is by diluting the
political power of citizens and that's
why democrats in new york are allowing
nearly a million foreign nationals here
illegally to vote in local elections
it's why gavin newsom has announced that
california is now going to offer
unlimited health care to illegal aliens
so that more of them will come that's
the point and it's why democrats are
pushing for what they describe as a
transformative voting rights bill it's
their top legislative priorities the
main thing they care about joe biden had
a speech about it this afternoon in
georgia the event didn't start well as
he has before biden referred to his
running mate as the president of the
united states if only
then as he almost always does during
public appearances these days joe biden
got angry watch
it's also time to pass the john lewis
voting rights advancement act i've been
having these quiet conversations with
members of congress for the last two
months i'm tired of being quiet
so what is this john lewis civil rights
act that groucho joe biden is tired of
being quiet about
well at its heart the bill would give
the federal government the power to
control how elections are conducted
across the country
the bill requires states to obtain
pre-clearance from the federal
government before they can set the rules
of their own elections what does this
mean well it means among other things
that states would no longer have the
authority to require voter
identification or registration at the
polls
states would also lose the power to pick
the locations for polling sites as well
as the ability to draw the boundaries of
their own congressional districts oh
that's what it's about before doing
virtually anything related to democracy
states would have to follow a formula
written by democrats that needless to
say focuses mainly on race why well the
idea is simple the idea is this country
is too racist to allow states to run
their own affairs nancy pelosi has to
run them only she is non-racist enough
to conduct elections
everything about that claim is absurd if
america's so racist then why have tens
of thousands of haitians snuck across
our border this year
nice to hear someone answer that
question or even ask it
but the idea itself is totally
unconstitutional we know this because
the supreme court was pretty clear about
it almost 10 years ago back in 2013 this
is not allowed it's never been allowed
and in fact no insane population would
ever allow it not voluntarily anyway why
would you let incumbent politicians rig
the game in their own favor well you
would not allow that you'd have to be
bullied into it how would you be bullied
you know the answer the fastest way to
bully americans other than by scaring
them with viruses
is to call them racist so of course
that's precisely what the democratic
party is doing right now they're telling
us the civil rights movement never
happened it's still 1951 in birmingham
and you my friend are bull connor shut
up and obey racist
joe biden's never been very subtle so
today he just came out and said it watch
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
to defend our elections to defend our
democracy
bull connor everyone under 70s thinking
football player who is that
but jefferson davis really
so if you oppose an unconstitutional
power grab by corrupt politicians in
their 80s you are the leader of a
confederacy
you're foreign combatant that's what he
said
that's how important it is to keep the
democratic party in power forever and
that's why we need to change the way the
senate votes so we'll never lose an
election again here's joe biden today we
must find a way to pass these voting
rights bill
debate them
vote let the majority prevail
and if that bare minimum is blocked
we have no option but to change the
senate rules including getting rid of
the filibuster for this
yeah
getting rid of the filibuster we could
go on about this you've heard it you
probably know but it's worth remembering
that the democratic party joe biden's
party invoked the filibuster more than
300 times recently oh not during the
civil rights movement that was in 2020
apparently they sided with bull connor
every time
so what's different well the threat of
white terror of course getting rid of
voter id laws is a matter of national
security biden explained
stand in the way and you may be a
terrorist once again the president
i will not yield i will not flinch i
will defend the right to vote our
democracy against all enemies foreign
and yes domestic
enemies within our own country we will
kill them
it's kind of amusing to see joe biden
call other people extremists the message
give me total power over your life or
else i'll know you're a dangerous
radical
it's pretty funny but it's also not
funny just hours before joe biden spoke
the doj the department of justice
announced the formation of a new
domestic terrorism unit what's it for
well you can read about it on the
website it's designed to hunt down and
punish anyone who opposes the federal
government or is otherwise quote
anti-authority anti-authority who's that
well pretty much at this point all
thinking people who aren't directly on
the federal payroll that means you
it means all of us got the message
if you think voters ought to show id at
the polls you could be hearing from the
fbi because you're a threat
on the other hand speaking papers you
should know that your covid papers are
still mandatory and becoming more so
because vax cards are not at all like
driver's licenses at polling places
they're not racist vax cards are holy
and they're essential
in fact in washington dc the mayor
muriel bowser has announced you're no
longer allowed outside without your
papers here's the quote
starting saturday you will need these
three things before heading out
proof of vaccination
12 years and over proof of vaccination
and photo id and a mask
otherwise you must stay in your house
because we own your body
that's muriel bowser who by the way is
not a dangerous extremist she can't be
because she's loyal to the regime hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else